[Music]
good morning everybody it's Yanis Pappas
from the studio which is really just my
dining room table so I mean doesn't even
matter Chrissy's in the bathroom I'm in
the bathroom
a my place in Montauk here I've been
talking about upping their ball it up
Chrissy your got it you got a drinking
problem you're banged up this is an
intervention I've gathered the
matriarchy together to say guess what
Bob was you're still drunk it's 9:00 in
the morning you're a German Northern
Irish cute kid handles liquor yeah okay
other my liquor we drink at home about
5:00 a.m. what can you do and you know
I'm going live from the bathroom because
my family's still sleeping but I'm here
I but I even though I'm drinking right
now I have I have my family's asleep and
I we have we are as soon as I wake up I
will have to make black lives matter
signs I will have them reach out to
local congressmen and Senators I will we
will absolutely stop racism out of
eastern Long Island yeah cuz I'm just a
little nervous with you drunk I mean
yeah I mean whenever you get begged up
you say I'm gonna can I tax the group
Chet and I said no just text me blah
blah because Chrissy clarice comes out
and the six-shooters just our fire
because it starts firing but what can
you do everyone sleep out there I got
[ __ ] bagels I got I'm trying to get
bagels but there's no bagel stores out
here so that's I think the issue is
knowing that are sober up I have a
couple of day goals but because I've
been drinking too much cuz he you sick a
little bit you think you could be sick a
little bit might be a little sick but
the good news is each Rossella buses
races TV show should be rated that we
booth he doesn't believe in censorship
well look this is I wanted to make it a
work a girl but vanity you found a
better one but I want to say work
Childress let's let's just hear him talk
cuz I get trucks not gonna make it now
let's go over to the United Arab
Emirates is trying to get to Mars with
with what they're calling the ambitious
Hope mission which would be the first of
three Mars launches schedule
this month so the United Arab Emirates
has a lot of money to spend on a nada
cuz make no mistake
they're not gonna be the first ones to
colonize Mars Elon Musk is gonna be
right Chrissy Chrissy's asleep Chrissy
is asleep this is the first web of the
boys are you saying I was asleep did you
pass out no no no I come on I heard you
saying that um that that they found sand
on Mars or something
pretty-pretty yeah that's pretty what
happened yeah that was the story
actually yeah cuz make no mistake
because I was drunk yesterday I started
firing off some messages and a tornado
read through montar so there was a
tornado that it wasn't a tornado watch
and then Chrissy got half of the bag and
then cuz just like cuz my great-great
grandfather I've told you before is
Jewish man so I like to put benadryl
cream on me I have a lot of Jewish
qualities about me that I love and
respect I'm wearing my glasses right now
to be in solidarity Ruth Bader Ginsburg
who's in the hospital but I do also
because I'm a Jew I do control the
weather and I brought a tornado to the
eastern Long Island seaboard yesterday
yeah cuz I mean if you and your baby's
mama were cartoons you would be a
tornado
she had a tsunami and then you guys
would just do this there's collateral
damage everywhere there's houses going
up
there's the others drinking brews
there's ants throwing racial slurs it's
just what happens it's just what it is
because sometimes you have one too many
floodlight shelters and there you just
TM so women you shouldn't beat the enemy
because there's one thing that's true
about you that I know yet I believe in
sensible gun safety laws even though I
am a gun owner and I also believe in
tech safety laws for your phone
there should be a safety button on your
text
it's just what cuz well I change my
passcode cuz my passcode was just
constant on my phone was always the
baby's birthday but so so she just knew
what it was but now I've changed it to
the 1975 but you'll never guess it
cuz you
keep looking around away from the
computer like you're expecting an
incoming Cinnabon thank you guys so much
for watching we hope you loved it don't
forget to click subscribe and turn your
alerts on and go to
patreon.com/crashcourse boys for more
fun where things get really bad
[Music]